Hello and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a podcast produced by the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Audrey Hamilton. In this episode, I talk with a psychologist about bringing feminism to young girls and teens who are coming of age in a challenging time. So there's all these things that show that, hey, we're equal and we've succeeded and we've arrived. And yet, obviously, we can look around our culture and see that we still have a long way to go. More than previous generations, today's teens are being brought up to believe girls can do anything, but they still face the challenges of being a teenage girl, and that does include increased rates of depression and low self-esteem. But according to our guest, feminist psychological
欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是一档由美国心理学会（APA）制作的播客。我是主持人奥黛丽·汉密尔顿（Audrey Hamilton）。在本期节目中，我和一位心理学家探讨了如何在这个充满挑战的时代，向步入青春期的年轻女孩和青少年普及女性主义。因此，所有这些事物都在表明，嘿，我们是平等的，我们成功了，我们已经达到了目标。然而，显而易见的是，环顾我们的文化，我们可以发现我们仍有很长的路要走。与前几代人相比，如今的青少年从小被灌输“女孩无所不能”的观念，但她们依然面临着作为少女的种种挑战，这确实包括不断上升的抑郁率和较低的自尊心。不过，根据我们的嘉宾所说，女性主义心理学
theory and practice could be used to better support teenage girls while giving them the courage to face the challenges of adolescence. Gail Pittman is a psychology and women's gender studies professor at Sacramento City College. She's also a children's book author and has written several books published by Imagination Press, focusing on LGBT issues for children. Her latest book is called Feminism A to Z. It's a hands-on introduction for teens and tweens who are interested in learning about feminism. Welcome, Dr. Pittman. Hi, thank you.
理论与实践可以用来更好地支持女青少年，同时赋予她们勇气去迎接青春期的挑战。盖尔·皮特曼（Gail Pittman）是萨克拉门托城市学院（Sacramento City College）的一位心理学以及女性与性别研究教授。她也是一位儿童读物作家，曾撰写过多本由想象力出版社（Imagination Press）出版的书籍，专注于儿童的LGBT议题。她的最新力作名为《女性主义A到Z》（Feminism A to Z）。这是一本面向对了解女性主义感兴趣的青少年和前青少年期儿童的实用入门书。欢迎您，皮特曼博士。您好，谢谢。
So your latest book, Feminism A to Z, I'm interested to hear what this book is about and who it's for. It is exactly what it sounds like. It's feminism from A to Z. It's intended as a book for teenagers and potentially older tweens kind of in that ballpark, depending on how mature the child is, basically giving kids an introduction to the world of feminism. And I structured it as an A to Z by chapter. So each chapter has a focus that's organized by letters. So like, for example, the first chapter is called A is for anger. And it outlines the reasons why girls and women might be angry about the various
那么，关于您的新书《女性主义A到Z》，我很想听听这本书讲的是什么，以及它的目标读者是谁。它正如听起来的那样，是一本关于A到Z女性主义的书。它旨在成为一本适合青少年以及潜在的稍大一些的前青少年期儿童的书，大致在这个年龄段，这主要取决于孩子的成熟度，基本上是为孩子们提供一个通往女性主义世界的入门指南。我以A到Z的章节形式来构建它。因此，每个章节都有一个按字母顺序组织的焦点。例如，第一章节名为“A代表愤怒（A is for anger）”。它概述了女孩和女性可能会对各种事情感到愤怒的原因
injustices that have been committed against them over the centuries, really. as well as how women and girls who are angry are perceived, right? Like anger and femininity tend not to go together, at least in our culture. So that's the focus for that chapter. And then each chapter also has a history focus, focusing on some element of women's history or feminist history or what have you. And then there's an activity called Try This. So it really gets kids into action, kind of out of their heads and into their hands and heart,
几个世纪以来对她们犯下的真正的不公正行为，以及人们如何看待愤怒的女性和女孩，对吧？比如愤怒和女性气质往往格格不入，至少在我们的文化中是这样。这就是该章节的重点。然后，每个章节还有一个历史焦点，聚焦于女性历史、女性主义历史或其他相关内容的某些元素。接着，有一个名为“试试这个（Try This）”的活动。所以它真的能让孩子们付诸行动，从他们的脑海中走出来，投入到他们的双手和心中
if you will, and finding ways to take action in their own lives. So it's really intended for a teenage audience, although you could scale it up or scale it back depending on the maturity of the child. I was just going to say, I imagine this is difficult because for teenagers and the kids that age, they're very much in their own heads and their own worlds, right? I mean, that is what is most important to them. So I'm curious, you know, why you thought that it's important to bring the message of feminism to a group like that.
如果你愿意的话，在他们自己的生活中寻找采取行动的方法。所以它确实是为青少年受众设计的，尽管你可以根据孩子的成熟度向上或向下调整。我正想说，我想这很困难，因为对于青少年和那个年龄的孩子来说，他们很大程度上沉浸在自己的脑海和世界里，对吧？我的意思是，这才是对他们最最重要的事。所以很好奇，你知道，为什么你认为向这样一个群体传递女性主义的信息很重要。
Right. Well, I teach women in gender studies at Sacramento City College, and so a lot of my students are 18, 19, 20 years old, sometimes older than that. And I think that that's usually the age where girls and women start to learn about feminism, start to become more aware. And yet, I think that if girls were introduced to some of the concepts of feminism earlier, that that could really help them weather the storms of adolescence. Because I think that not only are there the physical, and cognitive changes that happen during adolescence, there's also kind of a level of awareness that teens start to get, an awareness that the world may not be what they thought it was when they were children. They become more aware of sexism and racism and homophobia and transphobia and other types of injustices. And yet they may not necessarily, they have the cognitive tools to understand it intellectually, but they may not necessarily have the emotional tools or the maturity,
对的。嗯，我在萨克拉门托城市学院教授女性与性别研究，所以我的很多学生都是18、19、20岁，有时比这更大。而且我认为这通常是女孩和女性开始了解女性主义、开始获得更多意识的年龄。然而，我认为如果能让女孩们更早地接触到女性主义的一些概念，那将真正帮助她们度过青春期的风暴。因为我认为，在青春期不仅会发生身体和认知上的变化，还会产生某种程度的意识，即青少年开始意识到，世界可能不像她们小时候想象的那样。她们对性别歧视、种族主义、恐同症、恐跨症以及其他类型的不公正现象有了更多的认识。然而，她们可能不一定具备在知识上理解它的认知工具，但她们可能不一定具备情感工具或成熟度，
to be able to navigate those kinds of realities. And I think that feminism can offer a set of tools, if you will, to help them wrap their heads around this in their own lives. So that's really why I decided to write the book. Is there research out there to show that young girls, teenagers are more likely to identify as feminists than older generations? And, you know, do their ideas of feminism line up with older generations' ideas of feminism? Right. So there's really two questions there, right? Are millennials likely to call themselves feminists and why or why not, depending?
能够驾驭那种现实。我认为女性主义可以提供一套工具，如果你愿意的话，帮助她们在各自的生活中理解这一切。所以这就是我决定写这本书的原因。有没有研究表明，年轻女孩、青少年比老一辈人更有可能认同自己是女性主义者？而且，你知道，她们对女性主义的想法是否与老一辈人的想法相吻合？好的，这里其实有两个问题，对吧？千禧一代是否倾向于自称为女性主义者，以及为什么或为什么不？
And if they do, do their ideas of feminism line up with other generations? And so what I've seen in the research, and I haven't seen anything like super recently, but what I've seen over the years is that generally the further away we get from like the 1960s, 1970s era of feminism, the less likely we tend to see girls and women identifying as feminist. There was a bit of a blip during the 90s, which a lot of people refer to as the quote unquote third wave of feminism, although there's lots of people that don't like wave models necessarily, and there's some discussion of that in the book. I think that, especially for millennials, they're a generation that's kind of caught between a rock and a hard place. And what I
如果她们是，她们对女性主义的想法是否与其他代人一致？根据我在研究中看到的——虽然我没有看到过非常近期的研究，但我多年来看到的是，总的来说，我们距离20世纪60年代、70年代的女性主义时代越远，我们看到的女孩和女性认同为女性主义者的可能性就越小。在90年代曾有过一个小高潮，许多人称之为女性主义的所谓“第三次浪潮”，尽管有很多人不一定喜欢浪潮模型，书中对此也有一些讨论。我认为，特别是对于千禧一代，他们是一个处于进退维谷之境的一代。我的意思是
mean by that is that they're growing up in an era where they have more rights than ever before, right? Like they have the right to go to school, they have the right to learn how to read, they have the right to open up their own checking account, I mean, things that we just take for granted, which a couple of generations ago was not necessarily the case. And so there's all these things that, you know, show that, hey, we're equal and we've succeeded and we've arrived and yet obviously we can look around our culture and see that we still have a long way to go. And so because of that, I don't think that most teens and young adults today identify with like the old school kind of feminism of the 70s. And I think that's what a lot of people think
意思是他们成长在一个拥有比以往任何时候都多的权利的时代，对吧？比如他们有上学的权利，有学习阅读的权利，有开设自己支票账户的权利，我是说，这些我们视为理所当然的事情，在几代人之前却不一定如此。因此，所有这些事情都表明，嘿，我们是平等的，我们成功了，我们已经达到了目标，然而显而易见的是，环顾我们的文化，我们可以看到我们仍有很长的路要走。正因为如此，我认为当今大多数青少年和年轻成年人不认同70年代那种老派的女性主义。我想这也是很多人想到的
of when they think of feminism. You know, they think of like holding banners and marching and I don't know, burning their bras, which interestingly is a myth that never happened. But, you know, seriously. Is it really? Yes. Yeah. It was basically a form. of propaganda that was, you know, flooded throughout the media to try to convince people not to be feminist. And it worked because you still hear that phrase today. So I think that's what a lot of girls and young women think of when they think of feminism. And one of the things that I do with my students on the first day of class and my psych of women class is ask them to write down what words come to mind. We do sort of like a free association activity. What words
当他们想到女性主义时。你知道，他们会想到举着横幅、游行，还有，我不知道，烧毁她们的胸罩，有趣的是，这是一个从未发生过的神话。但是，说真的。真的吗？是的。嗯。这基本上是一种宣传形式，在整个媒体中泛滥，试图说服人们不要成为女性主义者。它起作用了，因为你今天仍然能听到这句话。所以我想这就是许多女孩和年轻女性在想到女性主义时的想法。我在课堂第一天以及我的女性心理学课上对我的学生做的事情之一，就是要求他们写下脑海中浮现的词汇。我们进行了一种自由联想活动。什么词
come to mind when they hear the word feminist? And it's so, fascinating because there's all these words that come up, some of which are empowering, some of which are really negative. And then we start to unpack the actual definitions of feminism and some of the different feminist philosophies. And that's one of the things that the early chapters of feminism from A to Z does is start to shine a light on the fact that there isn't just one way to be feminist. There's a variety of different approaches to it, a variety of different theoretical perspectives, depending on who you are, depending on your social location, depending on a variety of different things. And once students start to recognize that, then they're much more likely to buy into it.
当他们听到“女性主义者”这个词时会浮现出来？这太迷人了，因为会涌现出所有这些词，其中有些是赋予力量的，有些则是非常负面的。然后我们开始剖析女性主义的实际定义以及一些不同的女性主义哲学。这也是《女性主义A到Z》早期章节所做的事情之一，即开始阐明这样一个事实：成为女性主义者并不只有一种方式。它有各种不同的方法，各种不同的理论视角，这取决于你是谁，取决于你的社会地位，取决于各种不同的事情。一旦学生们开始认识到这一点，他们就更有可能接受它。
But I think it's the label. Like there's something about the word that kind of makes girls and, you know, makes millennials in particular say, oh, no, that's not me. That's, you know, that's something different. So in this age of social media, girls are also getting, I would say, very mixed messages about what's okay to share. what's the right way to do things. But it's also easy for them to connect with each other, find other people who share their views. How do you think social media is shaping the feminist movement now
但我认为问题出在标签上。这个词似乎有一种魔力，让女孩们，尤其是千禧一代说：“哦，不，那不是我。那是，你知道，那是完全不同的东西。”因此，在这个社交媒体时代，女孩们对于什么可以分享、什么才是做事的最正确方式，也接受到了可以说是非常混杂的信息。但同时，她们也很容易彼此联系，找到与自己观点相同的人。你认为社交媒体现在是如何塑造女性主义运动的
among younger generations, or is it hindering the movement? You know, I hear a lot of people say that millennials are not very politically active, right? Like they don't care about politics, they don't stay on top of social issues, et cetera. And I don't know, maybe I live in a bubble with my students, but I would disagree. I would say that they pay attention differently than previous generations did, and that a lot of their activism stems from social media. I mean, I think, for example, about the Black Lives Matter movement,
在年轻一代中，还是说它阻碍了这场运动？你知道，我听到很多人说千禧一代不是很积极参与政治，对吧？比如他们不关心政治，不关注社会问题等等。我不知道，也许我跟我的学生们生活在一个泡沫里，但我不同意这种说法。我认为他们关注的方式与前几代人不同，他们的许多行动主义都源于社交媒体。我的意思是，例如，我想到了黑人的命也是命（Black Lives Matter）运动，
which isn't necessarily a feminist movement, although there's a feminist intersection there, that started as a Twitter hashtag. I mean, that was an act of, you know, I mean, that was a form of social media activism. We think a number of years ago about the Occupy movement. That also started on social media. media. The March on Washington after the election where, you know, women across the country were
这不一定是一场女性主义运动，尽管其中有女性主义的交织点，但它是作为推特（Twitter）的一个话题标签开始的。我的意思是，那是一种行动，你知道，我的意思是，那是社交媒体行动主义的一种形式。我们回想一下几年前的占领（Occupy）运动。那也是在社交媒体上开始的。大选后的华盛顿大游行，全国各地的女性都在
knitting, you know, pink hats, you know, pink pussy hats. That started as a social media trend. And so I think there's a lot of opportunity for activism and connecting that way using various social media platforms. The downside that I see is that there's something very powerful about people physically getting together and having a conversation in real time that's not hindered by technology. And I don't know. I think it's a little early to tell whether or not it's social media and technology in general is a hindrance to that.
编织粉红色的帽子，粉红色的猫耳帽（pink pussy hats）。那是一个社交媒体趋势。所以我认为利用各种社交媒体平台，有很多机会进行行动主义和建立联系。我看到的缺点是，人们聚在一起进行面对面的交流，进行不受技术阻碍的实时对话，这具有非常强大的力量。我不知道。我认为现在判断社交媒体和整体技术是否对此构成了阻碍还为时过早。
I just see a lot less, you know, like personal engagement in that way. There's a lot of online engagement and technology-infused engagement. But in terms of face-to-face, like boots on the ground type of organizing, and even just brainstorming and, you know, just sharing, you know, sharing some everyone's narratives and life stories. I think that that's, it remains to be seen, I think, how social media impacts that process. Your work also focuses on educating students on LGBTQ history. You know, one of your other imagination press books when you look out the window. Can you talk a little bit about that book, what it's about?
我只是看到那种个人参与明显变少了。有很多线上参与和融入了技术的参与。但在面对面、扎根基层的组织工作方面，甚至仅仅是头脑风暴，以及分享、分享每个人的叙事和生活故事方面。我认为，社交媒体如何影响这个过程，还有待观察。你的工作还侧重于教育学生了解LGBTQ历史。你知道，你的另一本想象力出版社的书《当你望向窗外时》（When You Look Out the Window）。你能谈谈那本书以及它讲的是什么吗？
and why do you think it's important for parents and educators to teach children these stories? Right. So when you look at the window is a picture book biography about a lesbian activist couple, Phyllis Lyon and Del Martin, who if you live in the San Francisco Bay Area, like almost everybody knows who they are because they are just iconic. But if you live outside of that area, lots, you know, there's people within the LGBT community who may know who they are and what their contributions are. but I would say that the vast majority of people are just completely unfamiliar with their activism. And the reality is that they, I think in many ways, launched the LGBT movement back in the 1950s. I mean, we think about Stonewall, the Stonewall riots is kind of the beginning of the modern-day LGBT social justice movement. But if you go back a couple of decades earlier, back to the 1950s when Phyllis and Dell met and then moved in together, and started their activist journey.
以及为什么你认为父母和教育工作者向儿童讲授这些故事很重要？好的。所以《当你望向窗外时》是一本关于一对女同性恋活动家伴侣菲利斯·里昂（Phyllis Lyon）和德尔·马丁（Del Martin）的绘本传记。如果你住在旧金山湾区，几乎每个人都知道他们是谁，因为他们简直是偶像。但如果你住在那个地区之外，在LGBT群体中有很多可能知道他们是谁以及他们的贡献是什么，但我可以说，绝大多数人对他们的行动主义完全不熟悉。现实是，我认为他们在许多方面在20世纪50年代发起了LGBT运动。我的意思是，我们认为石墙运动（Stonewall）是现代LGBT社会正义运动的开端。但如果你把时间往前推几十年，回到20世纪50年代菲利斯和德尔相遇并同居的时候，开启了她们的活动家之旅。
The landscape was very harsh. I mean, it was the post-war era. It was the era of McCarthyism and the Red Scare and fear of anyone who was potentially communist or different or leftist or not mainstream in any way, whatever way. And that was the environment that Phyllis and Dell were living in in San Francisco. And instead of hiding or instead of kind of staying under the radar, are they were out and loud and proud and, you know, just like pounded the pavement until
当时的环境非常严酷。我的意思是，那是战后时代。那是麦卡锡主义（McCarthyism）和红色恐怖（Red Scare）的时代，对任何可能是共产主义者、异见者、左翼分子或任何不是主流的人都充满恐惧。这就是菲利斯和德尔在旧金山生活的环境。她们没有选择隐藏，也没有选择保持低调，而是公开、大声、骄傲地发声，你知道，就像踏踏实实地努力，直到
Dell died in 2008. And so I think that their story is really powerful and that is one of the reasons that I wanted to write this. And the other thing, kind of going to your second question, is that I worry a lot that these narratives, if they don't get written down or if they don't get passed down in some way, shape, or form, that they're going to get lost. I mean, there's lots of LGBT history that's already been lost, largely because LGBT people typically don't live in families with other LGBT people. They're kind of in isolation and have to find community in some way. So there isn't that kind of natural passing down of stories, you know, that kind of oral tradition, that oral narrative that you see, say, in communities of color, other marginalized groups where
德尔在2008年去世。所以我认为她们的故事非常强大，这也是我想写这本书的原因之一。另一个原因，有点像你的第二个问题，我非常担心这些 narratives（故事）如果不被写下来，或者如果不以某种形式或方式传承下去，它们就会丢失。我的意思是，有许多LGBT历史已经丢失了，主要是因为LGBT人群通常不与其他LGBT人群生活在一个家庭中。她们处于某种隔离状态，必须以某种方式寻找社区。因此，并没有那种自然的叙事传承，你知道你在有共同身份的有色人种社区或其他边缘化群体中看到的那种口头传统、口头叙事。
people have shared identities. In the LGBT community, that's a much more difficult kind of process. And so if people aren't writing these down or recording them in some way, it's easy for those stories to get lost. And I'm seeing it already in my classroom. I mean, when I teach about sexuality and gender, lots of my students don't know anything about the Stonewall riots. They've never heard of Phyllislein and Del Martin. They didn't know about McCarthyism and the Red Scare. Increasingly, and this is really scary to me, considering that this is within my own lifetime, there's lots of students that are unaware about the magnitude of the AIDS crisis.
在LGBT社群中，这是一个难得多的过程。因此，如果人们不把这些故事写下来或以某种方式记录下来，这些故事就很容易丢失。我已经从我的课堂上看到了这一点。我的意思是，当我教授性和性别时，我的很多学生对石墙运动一无所知。他们从未听说过菲利斯·里昂和德尔·马丁。他们不知道麦卡锡主义和红色恐怖。越来越严重的是，考虑到这发生在我自己的一生中，这让我感到非常害怕，许多学生对艾滋病危机的规模一无所知。
And the ways in which the government did or didn't intervene to try to prevent further deaths from happening. And so when they learn of this, they become, number one, surprised. And then number two, really angry, especially my LGBTQ-identified students. I mean, the first question they'll ask is, how come nobody ever taught us this? This is unbelievable. And I think it's a symptom of a larger problem of history, is not necessarily getting passed down. And I think a great place to start is with children. Yeah.
以及政府当时是否干预以试图防止更多死亡发生的方式。所以当他们了解这一点时，他们首先感到惊讶，其次是真的很生气，尤其是我的LGBTQ身份的学生。我的意思是，他们问的第一个问题是：为什么从来没有人教过我们这些？这太不可思议了。我认为这是历史没有得到传承这一更大问题的症状，而我认为一个很好的起点就是从孩子开始。是的。
This is kind of just a side question, but I'm curious, you're a psychologist, you're a college professor. Tell me how you got involved in writing children's books. That's a fair question. You know, like what was it about children's books? And I think you touched a little bit just now on that, you know, like you said, like passing down these stories to children, you know, or somewhere to start with that, right? Right, right. Yeah, this is actually, it's good that you ask that question because my path to writing children's book is a kind of twisty and turny one. So I have a friend outside of my academic work and psychology and all of that,
这只是一个旁支问题，但我很好奇，你是一名心理学家，你是一名大学教授。告诉我你是如何涉足儿童读物写作的。这是一个合理的问题。你知道，是什么让你对儿童读物感兴趣？我想你刚才已经提到了一点，你知道，就像你说的，把这些故事传承给孩子们，你知道，或者从某个地方开始，对吧？对，对。是的，其实你问这个问题很好，因为我走上儿童读物创作的道路是一个曲折的过程。所以在我的学术工作、心理学以及所有这些之外，我有一个朋友，
who's a children's book writer and illustrator. And she was an academic in children's writing and creative writing at a university. And she, at some point in her career, decided to step back from academia and do her writing and illustrating full time and also launch writing classes. So she had just moved to Sacramento. She was launching her very first class. She was trying to drum up business. I ran into her one day.
她是一位儿童书作家兼插画家。她曾是一所大学的儿童文学和创意写作学者。在她职业生涯的某个时刻，她决定退出学术界，全职从事写作和插画工作，并开设写作班。所以她刚刚搬到萨克拉门托。她正在开办她的第一个班。她试图招揽生意。有一天我遇到了她。
she was telling me about her class, and she basically twisted my arm. And I'm not fabulous at saying no. So I said yes. And then afterwards, I was like, oh, my gosh, I can't believe I said yes to this. I can't do this. I don't have time. Blah, blah, blah. But, oh, my gosh, this class was unbelievable.
她跟我讲了她的班级，她基本上说服了我。而我不太擅长拒绝别人。所以我答应了。事后我在想，哦天哪，我真不敢相信我答应了这事。我做不到。我没有时间。巴拉巴拉。但是，哦天哪，这个班简直不可思议。
It was so much fun. It just opened up a whole different area of my brain, I guess you could say, a whole different form of creativity. And it was once I started doing that type of. writing and then getting a sense of the landscape of kids' books and seeing what was there, but also what wasn't there, like who wasn't being represented in children's books and what wasn't being written about, that I got even more motivated to start focusing my energy in that direction. Well, great. Well, Dr. Pittman, thank you so much for joining us. It's been a pleasure. Thank you. Thanks for listening. Make sure you check out our other episodes of Speaking of Psychology
太有趣了。我想你可以说，它打开了我大脑中一个完全不同的领域，一种全新的创造力形式。正是一旦我开始从事那种写作，并对儿童读物的现状有了感觉，看到那里面有什么，但也看到那里没有什么，比如谁没有在儿童读物中得到代表，有什么没有被书写，这让我更加有动力开始将我的精力集中在这个方向上。太棒了。那么，皮特曼博士，非常感谢您加入我们。这真是个荣幸。谢谢。谢谢收听。请务必查看我们的其他《心理学谈话》节目
and please subscribe if you haven't already. We are a proud member of the APA Podcast Network. which includes other great podcasts such as APA Journal's Dialogue. You should check that out if you want to hear about the latest and most exciting psychology research. If you are interested in the practice of psychology, be sure to listen to progress notes. Topics include how health care policy and social media affect practicing psychologists. You can find those podcasts on iTunes and Stitcher or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website, speakingofpsychology.org, to listen to even more episodes. and gather more resources on the topics we discussed.
如果您还没有订阅，请订阅。我们是APA播客网络（APA Podcast Network）的自豪成员，该网络还包括其他精彩播客，例如《APA期刊对话》（APA Journal's Dialogue）。如果您想了解最新、最令人兴奋的心理学研究，您应该去听听。如果您对心理学的实践感兴趣，请务必收听《进展纪要》（progress notes）。话题包括医疗保健政策和社交媒体如何影响执业心理学家。您可以在iTunes、Stitcher或您获取播客的任何地方找到这些播客。您还可以访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org，收听更多节目，并收集有关我们讨论话题的更多资源。
Thanks for joining us. I'm Audrey Hamilton with the American Psychological Association, and this is Speaking of Psychology. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这里是《心理学谈话》。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。